voilà vous l'avez reconnu invité de
notre journal jean louis trintignant
l'un des interprètes d'un très beau film
l'instinct de l'ange que vous pourrez
découvrir après demain sur vos écrans
c'est l'histoire résumée d'un jeune
homme qui pendant la guerre de 14
bien que tuberculeux et donc en principe
réformer tient absolument à apprendre à
voler pour participer au combat aérien
à force de volonté cet homme interprété
par lambert wilson y parviendra mais son
exigence morale va l'isoler de plus en
plus de ses camarades d'escadrille tout
de suite un extrait
bien au chaud cette embauche fonce et
frugale capitaine
[ __ ] c'est votre part
aujourd'hui suivez pas refroidir tu peux
me trilles et vous mon capitaine
mon colonel vous voulez bien motorisé
prenez le moral biplace avec garber à
l'égard d'air comme mitrailleur
fauconnet si ce jeune homme revient
vainqueur il ne sera plus jamais humble
jean louis trintignant suis très heureux
de vous accueillir sur ce plateau vous
avez une très très bonne formule vous
avez dit c'est un film qui volent ou une
belle formule c'est vrai c'est un film
qui rend intelligent c'est un film
d'anton sort vraiment exalté et
intelligent je crois c'est un film sur
la différence sur la difficulté d'être
différent oui c'est à dire que dans un
groupe quand quelqu'un est trop doux est
trop fort il met en péril
l' équilibre du groupe alors c'est vous
à tf1 voilà on est à france 2 mai donc
c'est votre problème on l'a vu vous êtes
le colonel enfin vous êtes au chef de
cette escadrille vous avez beaucoup de
sympathie pour ce pour ce héros mais
votre problème c'est la cohésion du
groupe et l'exigence morale de ce héros
mais en fait en cause l'existence du
groupe et il va finir par cristalliser
toutes les ressentiments
oui c'est ça je veux pas tellement
parler de mon personnage sinon que c'est
pas un vrai militaire c'est un militaire
mais à cette époque là les gens qui
faisait qui servait dans l'aviation
pendant la guerre de 14 n'était pas des
aviateurs c'est à dire que le corps
d'armes des aviateurs n'existait pas il
a existé plus tard c'était des gens qui
venaient d'autres d'autres armes
certains étaient tirailleurs et ce qui
était passionné par la vie l'aviation
avaient été réunis dans un groupe et a
été des aviateurs c'est à dire que
c'était un petit peu des marginaux dans
l'armée voilà est-ce que vous adhérez à
l'affirmation selon laquelle quand on
est un petit peu trop différent des
autres renvoient les autres à leur
médiocrité on cristallise un peu en
quelque sorte oui c'est terrible à dire
mais c'est la vérité absolument cocteau
a dit deux phrases très joli il a dit
pour établir l'égalité il faut couper
toutes les têtes qui dépassent
c'est terrible mais c'est vrai j'ai lu
dans une interview à me dire si c'est
vrai ou pas que vous aviez une blonde
conversation avec l'un votre fils et
voulait bien un petit peu tenu ce
discours à savoir tout le monde ne peut
pas voler sur les six mais il faut
savoir assumer sa différence voire sa
médiocrité dans les sens du terme c'est
à dire j'ai pris les choses un peu dans
le sens contraire
mon fils ne voulait pas être normal il
voulait être exceptionnel comme beaucoup
d'enfants c'est très beau d'ailleurs
comme beaucoup d'adolescents c'est très
beau je trouve ça très beau mais enfin
le c'est vrai je lui ai dit un peu le
contraire je lui ai dit il faut que tu
assumes que la médiocrité alors qu'il
n'est pas particulièrement médiocre mais
pas du tout mais on peut peut-être dire
un mot du metteur en scène richard
gbagbo qui est un homme tout à fait
atypique dans le milieu du cinéma
puisque son dernier film qui était tout
à fait extraordinaire la diagonale du
fou date de 80 même c'est très très rare
un metteur en scène qui est qui met huit
ans pour faire un autre film où ça
arrive quelquefois quand les metteurs en
scène non pas de succès mais lui a eu un
succès énorme
il a eu le l'oscar à hollywood du
meilleur film étranger
donc ils avaient toutes les possibilités
qu'il voulait pour faire d'autres films
et il a attendu huit ans pour faire ce
film c'est quelqu'un de très très
extraordinaire de très doué d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas s'il est pas trop doux et
même pour rentrer dans ce milieu tout
dernière question je suis très content
que vous recevoir parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour vous vous
faites assez rare question toute bête
pourquoi outil peu de présents sur les
grands écrans on vous propose que des
rôles qui vous intéresse pas ou vous
voulez personnellement prendre de la
distance surtout ça bah oui parce que je
je me suis réveillé à 60 en dix ans
enfin peu avant même qu'ils appelleront
tant que cette soixante ans mais je me
suis réveillé en me disant il faut quand
même prendre le temps de vivre
je crois que on n'est pas obligé de
passer à la télévision pas vous c'est
votre métier
mais moi on n'est pas obligé de passer à
la télévision qu'on parle de vous pour
être heureux je crois même que ça rend
pas tellement heureux une région si
contenant bien cet hommage c'est pas
quelque chose qui vous manque tout de
même non non la région que ce soit
chaque tournage que ce soit un bonheur
mais il faut aussi être très exigeant je
crois si on veut que ce soit le bonheur
voilà on profite beaucoup des choses
complètes sont rares alors définition
merci beaucoup jean louis trintignant un
projet tout de même vous avez d'autres
d'autres rivages et quelques projets une
pièce ou un autre film voyage cette
année je vais faire une pièce de théâtre
et je vais jouer dans deux autres films
merci beaucoup merci peut pas aller les
filles avec qui qui seul ce qui est
pierre goux pierre boutron boutron
pierre boutron pardonnez moi j'ai perdu
30 merci beaucoup de ghazi la barre
était notre invité je rappelle pour nos
téléspectateurs que vous ils pourront
retrouver les dialogues de ce film qui
sont tout à fait super dans un bouquin
qui vient de paraître aux éditions
verdier